[Music] citizens of the reject Nation it's me here
Ericson alongside this guy I know his name what
is it Andrew Flash Gordon is that your middle name
flash it's just a nickname that somebody's brother
on this channel gave me God I missed out on all
of that I thought it was his actual middle name
and it would made me like him more listen today
we're going to watch shudder Island we have never
seen it all I know is it's got Leo deap in it and
I'm down for that leave a like leave a comment
and also don't forget to ring the bell ring the
bell and if you haven't joined patreon we call
you super sexy over there and you can sync up
with your own copy in wat shatter island with
me and Andrew Andrew is a book of references
I am not so he'll make a lot of those I won't
I'll just be I don't know doing Terra stuff I
guess also Greg and John have exclusive watch
alongs and highlights over there on patreon so
you just just get over there it become super
sexy you know the deal listen are you ready to
watch us Andrew oh I'm so excited let's do it
right I'm already liking the music
oh aat it was so foggy yesterday
too pull yourself together titty pull yourself
together oh God sea sickness it's just water
it's a lot of water he's like I was already
on water and Titanic I know how this works
I I don't want to be here also like you have
seasickness right you're not just afraid of
water I guess we'll find out hey it's the
Hulk look at him Mark Ruffalo he looks so
handsome some in the shot you're my new partner
that's right how long you been with the marshs 4
years what about you you got a girl B I was
oh he's wearing that tie [Music] today oh
Michelle she died a there was a fire at the
apartment building while I was at work four
people died it was a smoke the gner not the fires
that's a good observation on the tie I didn't even
give you a briefing about the institution before
you left all I know is it's a mental hospital well
it's just folks running around hearing voices and
chasing after butterflies they wouldn't eat us oh
getting on to the island quickly all right we are
wasting no time the island of the insane the other
side of the island is Rock Bluffs all the way down
to the edge of the water the dock it's the only
way on WE off love it hey the scope of it is been
also the isolation too so Eerie it makes it feel
yeah very like spooky and ominous I'm Deputy
W mcf and gentlemen welcome to Shadow Island
I'll be the one taking you up to [Applause]
ashcliff this music is really setting us up
yeah wow that's an incredible shot
yeah you know this would be a perfect place for
a haunted house I feel like yeah everybody's just
got to shuttle on a yeah take the boat to the to
the island Bo for three hours to get there I would
do it hell I would do it too electrified perimeter
can you tell seen something like it before is Ward
a the male Ward Ward B the female Ward is the one
on your left Ward C the most dangerous patients a
house there admittance to w c is forbidden without
the written consent and physical presence of both
myself and Dr Cary you're hereby required to
surrender your Firearms okay let's get out of
here yeah what why I mean they probably have
more training than the federal penitentiary
guys oh maybe not when did she Escape I'm
afraid Dr colie will have to fill you in on the
situation whoa she looks haunted on the
inside
yep hey Ben Kingsley I didn't know he was in
this two Marvel actors here the Hulk and Trevor
Slattery female prisoner patient Rachel candoo
last night between 10 and midnight she considered
dangerous she killed all three of her children
oh oh the most dangerous of all my one held their
heads under till they died then she brought them
back inside and arranged them around the kitchen
table she ate a meal there before a neighbor
dropped by oh my God my God and what about the
husband he died on the beaches at Normandy she's
a war widow she stared herself when she first came
here she insisted the children weren't dead oh oh
my God I love her Emily Mor yeah wait was that who
she he saw on the contacts no uh no today I'm a a
little more prone to seasickness ah dehydration in
that case you're quite right the simpler the
better thanks so much Rachel Su believes the
children are alive ah to sustain the delusion
that her children never died she's created an
elaborate fictional structure and she gives us all
parts to play in that fiction jeez I should start
trying that out in real life that's elaborate
we don't know how she got out of her room it
was locked from the outside and the only Windows
barred I'd ask her about surveillance but this
is 54 so she's a witch How many pairs of shoes
are the patients given two pairs she left here
Barefoot dig her way out like alcatra [Music]
style who is 67 I think it's just random
scribblings oh Rachel smart this paper
could be important excuse me doctor this is
evidence it's a clue last night there were
seven men sitting at the base of those stairs
playing stud poker yet somehow Rachel managed
to slip past them sounds like a conspiracy we're
going to need to speak with the staff I feel like
they killed room after dinner if you have any
further questions feel free to join the deputy
warden in the search this location's incredible
though yeah it's 11 mil to the nearest land and
the water's freezing tent was strong last night
she had drowned have been crushed on the rocks
and a body would have washed back up on shore
loving all these like crane shots yeah they're
awesome the cinematography is great so far who
else does she have to pass to get down here me
oh he was in Jack Reacher and you were at your
post all night yeah but I didn't see a thing
uhhuh yeah he's lying he's looking down when he
answer the question tell me the truth and maybe
went to the bathroom Miss saland was putting her
room for lights out does anyone here know what
she did before that she was in a group therapy
session anything unusual occur this is a mental
institution usual isn't a big part of our day good
point you were there was there a doctor present
Dr Shen led the discussion he's Rachel's primary
the psychiatrist who directly oversees her care
have we not met him yet I don't think so we're
going to need to speak with Dr Sheen I'm afraid
that won't be possible what he left on the ferry
this morning a dangerous patient has escaped and
you let her primary doctor leave yeah on a fairy
the doctor and her are doing the juice he took
her away maybe I wonder if she escaped on that
fairy hello anybody there all communication on
the island down down all the lines yeah uh great
plan like afraid of the rain it's going to shut
down communication she happens to be very smart
but I'll be having drinks in a cigar at my house
around 9: we can talk then right we have been
talking Marshall he's got some kind of sinister
Vibe about himy hiding a secret right [Music]
yeah got to say I'm thinking I got in the wrong
line of Public Service seriously yeah where do
I sign up to be a psychiatrist nice music who is
that [Music] brms it's marer forgive me gentleman
my colleague Dr Jeremiah net for piano Max vono we
saw him an exorcist yes your profession doctor
Psychiatry yes I always heard it was overrun
with boozes and drunks not that I've noticed is
he's drinking what's that ice tea in your glass
there excellent Marshall you have outstanding
defense mechanisms don't you dare analyze me I
feel like that doctor who was just the Exorcist
guy was just like brought him in for a reason
not of a stretch DOC for all you know we're
were both paper pushers over there no you are
[Music] not oh boy it's a lot
of red and Ledger huh ah I had
a feeling that's where we were going
here yeah yeah and who raced you me
wolves very impressive defense [Music] mechanisms
yeah normally I'd have sympathy but you
know he's the nword so uh not at all Evil
Soul oh boy yes uh delete him delete him right now
please yeah as a Jew you may delete him or just
let him do it himself right or you could just let
him bleed out maybe yeah be let him let him just
uh wall up in pain nice yeah you be in pain sir
yeah despicable being yeah uh seen a death camp
doctor conent English English is z good fast
perfect his English really is very good he hit
the consonant a tad hard though oh is he ziming
we're going to need those files on Sheen and the
rest of the staff as well out of the question
[__] out of the question who is in charge
here anyway huh yeah exactly we're going to
file our reports and we're going to hand it
over to Ho's boy Hoover's boys that's right
we taking the fer back in the morning if they
make it there love Leo's tempers we haven't
heard the truth once Yet chuck listen Rachel
solo didn't slip out of a locked cell Barefoot
without any help no crap yeah but the thing is
if she did get help why did they call it in
and then like right I'm curious about that
maybe it's to get the the psychiatrist that
helps her like maybe the psychiatrist messed
up too and they're trying to like put it on her
I'm very curious how this cuz like why is heol I
found a whole stack of these Teddy Jesus are you
ever sober anymore killed a lot of people he's
got major PTSD is that why you drink it's not
why I drink I just like it yeah you real amen
no she's still here who oh Emily Mortimer she
never [Music] left W that's a awesome shot yeah
these shots are incredible that's beautiful
remember when we stayed in the cabin in the
summer Teddy was so happy she's here you can't
leave what I'm not going to leave I love you so
much
a you have to wake up wow go wow this is a
beautiful work of art in regards to how they're
shooting this you have to face that but she is
so is he who lers please I need a whole [Music] a
a wow
oh oh wow oh okay oh yeah it's going to say how
what how did that happen oh great they're not
going to be able to get out of there now going to
say are they going to be able to leave there's no
way she was so sweet but you could see it in
her eyes she liked to be naked to suck what I
did not expect that she drowned her kids this
is a sick world we live in I'll tell you that
you know what they should be gassed oh oh boy
the your the [__] oh this Shutter Island is
getting worse and worse with every word that
nurse maybe maybe she had kids huh a husband
is trying to make ends meet a normal life Nails
on a chalkboard for him yeah could you stop that
please please please stop don't patient Nam manre
latus do you no no I want to go back come on Leo's
just got this intensity he really just so good
yeah the second he he gets stopped he just when
he pulled back got it so great you seem quite
quite normal the difference is uh most people
don't kill their husbands with an axe if a man
beats you and half the women he sees and no one
will help you he had it coming I mean sure and
Dr Sheen was there that night yes he talked about
anger what's he like he reminds me of my husband
okay nice um did he ever make a pass at you no Dr
Shan's a good doctor he would never could I have
a glass of water please no problem feel like maybe
this Milkman delivery man whatever is like a
oh madeup line that they tell him to [Music]
say
uh what oh I don't know what she wrote did you
ever meet a patient named Andre lus never heard
of her oh God like they're all lying but why
requested it specifically you understand what
Andrew lus the maintenance man in the apartment
building where my wife and I live what okay
there's also a fire bug Andrew lus lit the match
that caused the fire that killed my wife oh oh
that changes things about a year ago I opened
up the paper and there he is he burned down a
Schoolhouse killed two people said voices told
him to do it first he went to prison then he
got transferred here oh pretty sure he's not in
Ward B that leaves Ward C oh it could be dead
so could Rachel cando for that matter lot of
places to hide a body here only one place no
one would really notice are they going into W
see Bridget Kar when she sent me for water she
said something to you back there didn't she no she
didn't technically say anything yeah she wrote it
down oh okay God this wind and this rain I don't
know how they shot it because it looks it it's
convincing yeah well obviously we don't get this
type of weather here but right ah oh my goodness
wow they yeah no it really does look convincing
yeah it's like the war what is when
we got through the gates at doal the
SS God surrendered the common dant tried
to kill himself before we got there but
he botched it took him an hour to die oh that
was his own okay got it that makes sense when
I went outside I saw all the bodies on the
ground I've seen so many history videos it's
terrible oh God the worst thing that would give
such PTSD to have witnessed that horror on top of
actually being in War I just for survival the god
surrendered we took their guns we lined them up
normally I'm for taking prisoners but in this case
I'm you're like bye-bye now you all die like yeah
like what kind of effed up world are we living in
that you thought that would be okay yeah well I
mean wow what an insane shot I mean yeah it
was amazing y'all took the lives of millions
of innocent men women and children so starved
them yeah hard hard to have sympathy on y'all
you think that's going on here like I said no
one would talk right till I found somebody who
used to be a patient here guy's name is George
noise nice college kid socialist sounds noise
yeah he almost beats his Professor to death
ends up here in ashcliff Ward seed oh boy so
what do you really here to do Ted I'm going to
get the proof I'm going to go back and I'm going
to blow the lid off this place are you able
to get off this place waiting for a chance
to get out here and then suddenly they need a US
Marshal I got lucky there was a patient Escape it
was the perfect excuse the world doesn't work
that way they got an electrified fence around
a septic facility exactly that's what I'm they
knew who you were before getting in here right
everything about this place stinks a government
Ops what if they wanted you here [__] you were
asking questions [__] oh there's no way they
could have known I'd be a to the SK there's no
way well you were looking into them they were
looking into you all they had to do is fake
and escape to get you here and now they have
you now they have us both it's a conspiracy
W Marshall are you out here this is Deputy w m
that's a great shot in the middle of the ocean
during a hurricane a lot of flooding seems like
a distinct possibility it's a gamble Steven say
the power fails there's a backup generator and
if that goes the cell doors will open oh boy 24
human beings I put all 42 inwards A and B in
manual restraints as well you said you had no
idea what that second line could refer to who
was 67 24 patients and 42 patients a total of
what 66 patients at this facility oh one's
missing what seems to me Rachel solando is
suggesting that you have a 67th patient
doctor didn't mcferson tell you the good
news Rachel's been found what what so who's
the 67 seventh patient hey I love her so much
know she's so good but she's there she is it's
so antil climate like so what it's got to be
it's got to be the the the German doctor guy
there's been a sighting of a known communist
subversive in this area passing out literature
M if you could tell us what you did yesterday
where you were I made breakfast for Jim and
the children packed Jim's lunch and he left
and I sent the children off to school and then
I decided to take a long swim in the lake after
that uh what this is getting dark
I thought of you huh don't you know
how long have been she mistaking him
for her husband how am I supposed to
survive car I'm so sorry but
everything's going to be all
right I buried you I buried an empty casket your
body rained down lumps of Flesh splashing into
the sea eaten by sharks my Gym's dead so who
the who are you oh no idea how she got out but
I'm going to have to ask you to go down into
the basement there's food water and cots are
they poisoning him like why does he keep getting
these headaches so goddamn bright is is it are
you having a [Music] migraine what's wrong with
Marsh couple of hours you'll be as clear as a
B's he's having a migraine imagine someone sort
open your head yeah he's spring the back of the
head sure everything's is he being put in with
the patience is it oh cuz was there flooding who
is that him that's the war they're they're just
meeting the warden now right what what is going
on here this is some weird conspiracy it looks
like an exmilitary prick huh you know what I
ain't going to argue with you on that one I mean
you're right it does feel like he's been drugged
right like all these things are happening I feel
like Mark Ruffo had a really good point and also
where's that psychiatrist that went away on
the fery that day nothing makes sense right
[Music]
now this music with the way this is oh [Music]
yep right this music is freaking me out yeah
it's like giving me underlying anxiety the
way that it's done yeah you don't know when
that dumbbells is going to come up you should
have saved me you should have saved all of
us does he feel some sort of I mean I know
he feels I know I would assume he feels some
kind of guilt that he couldn't save his wife
in the fire but Ian does he feel that in the
war too I feel like with his flashbacks the
way he talks about it I feel like he hey
Elias CZ Casey Jones T mut Ninja Turtles
yes sir great actor hey buddy oh that's the
the actor who or the character of [Music]
yeah that had some crazy makeup no hard
feelings right no hard feelings don't
trust that man with fire does that man even
exist right now this is what a dreamer all
in his head like it's all in his head like the
flashback wife right oh yeah running out of the
[Music] time whoa did you see that Holy junk how
the smoke see went back in ah I could get into
trouble oh my God this is so hard to look at I
know it's not real but still I'm so sorry why
didn't you see me but by the time I got there
it was too late [Music] that is one freaky
nightmare is his wife who the hell is this oh his
wife yeah so he woke up to this you
you need to find him and you kill him
dead backup generators failed whole place
is going crazy oh God Christ relax no okay
so they got released and all the doors opened
right yeah yeah yeah I guess I'd be asking for
my weapon back electrical system is fried feels a
Jurassic parkes yeah right nice day for a stroll
don't you think toward C for example maybe
we'll run into Andrew lus oh that's a good
point they might run into him we got most of
the bugs he's locked down now but some of them
are still loose and if you see one don't try to
restrain them yourselves these will kill you if
he runs into that guy he's not going to try and
restrain him going to do something else to him
yeah God the atmosphere they've created
in this movie it's great I I keep
thinking like wow why is nobody done a
Shutter Island haunted house seriously
like that would miss opportuni so far
such an experience oh yeah I can feel
him tag you're in that's that's a fun game
yeah but probably just no it's too dark oh
God losing him in the shadows
tag you're it oh that was good timing you
were like so in sync I was like have you
seen this how did you get that so uh I took
a wild guess I don't want to leave here all
right we hear things here about TOS about each
bomb test you know how a hydrogen bomb Works
other bombs explode right it implodes creating an
explosion to the thousands the the Millions the G
oh catch them not killed them he jumped us I
mean to be fair it was technically selfdefense
guy was in a headlock for like a good five
minutes had him there yeah he didn't like
just no jump all of a sudden on him and start
beating him I mean that guy could have killed
him those 10 times the
sound design in this is like
wow running out of mat
this
lus that's pretty damn funny is it him let me
see a goddamn face now what so you can lie to
me more this isn't about the truth yes it is it's
about Expos the truth what about you I don't think
it's him I was incidental a way in oh Jackie Earl
haly George no you can't be here you like it who
did this to you George you did tell me how they
got you here they know the whole plan this is a
game you're not investigating anything oh is he
the test subject you talking about Leo yes yeah
I think is he 67 I think he might be number 67
yeah he's a US Marshal you never worked with
him before have you cuz everything has seemed too
convenient up until this point till he just said
that she's dead let her go tell him about the
day you brought me my locket you got to do it
I can't you have to let it go I can't then you'll
never leave this island revenge or the truth he's
not in this W he's transfered if he's not in w a
only one place he can be wait are I thought they
were in W C they are so is he saying White House
oh okay it's an interesting year for Jackie Earl
Haley because he's he did this and he did Freddy
Krueger nightmare in Elm Street this year this
is a far superior film his intake for him the
only thing in his files yeah take a look I'll
look at it later it's met boys look it over later
that's all uh not trusting him anymore yeah not
after what he heard you brought me into this boss
and now we're trapped here on this rock no one to
rely on but each other and now you're you're
acting like like what like what like you're
crazy damn it I knew it wouldn't
take long but I couldn't get to it
the tide was up Chuck Chuck leave the
form for him or oh no what is this he
jumped oh no oh okay
[Music] what come
[Music]
on what [Music]
M
[Music]
no wonder if uh BL is in or oh is that Emily
who are you I think it's Emily her I'm a cop
it looks like Marshall Laura no no it's not her
it's a different lady I'm going to keep this if
you don't mind it's fine by me Rachel solando what
the real one oh did you kill your children what I
never had children what is going on and before
I was a patient at ashcliff I worked here what
what oh once you're declared insane then anything
you do is called part of that Insanity reasonable
protest or denial survival instincts are you're
smarter than you look Marshall I started asking
about these large shipments of sodium amatol
and opium based hallucinogens psychotropic drugs
ever heard of a transorbital labotomy oh I was
going to say is labotomy he at the patient with
electroshock and go through the eye with an ice
pick NOP m pull out some ner fibers I don't want
to see that please don't cut to that just the
description recreate a man so he doesn't feel
pain or love or or or sympathy the Pain part I
like everything else now I don't want to be a
zombie to have that kind of ability that kind of
knowledge that that would take years years years
of research hundreds of patients to experiment on
oh they're experimenting on these okay these are
their guinea pigs the Nazis use a jeice Soviets
use prisoners in their own guls and we tested
patients on shedar island wow so now he's got a
moral decision the truth or his wife's killer so
that when they commit you here your friends and
colleagues oh yeah that makes sense cuz he's been
obsessed with his wife's death they can say that
about anyone anyone at all point is are going to
say it about you yeah how's your head oh cuz the
migrant yeah tell us they have been drugging him
I am prone to migraines yes you haven't taken any
pills I mean even aspirin the the aspirin you ate
the food in the cafeteria and drunk the coffee
they gave you leis said you've been smoking your
own cigarettes uh it takes 36 to 48 hours for
neuroleptic narcotics to reach workable levels
in the bloodstream oh no uhoh tell me what goes
on in that Lighthouse brain surgery now let's
open the skull and see what happens if we pull
on this car oh God who knows about this everyone
everyone wow total conspiracy I guess we know we
have that German doctor too I had a friend I was
with him yesterday but we got separated have you
seen him you have no friends cold hard truth but
that scene definitely filled in a lot of planks
yeah that Carly thinks you're harmless that you
can be controlled but I know different you don't
know me oh but I do oh I know you we've known
each other for centuries what if I was to sink
my teeth into your eye right now would you be
able to stop me before I blinded you only one way
to find out give it a try apparently there was an
unidentified man in Ward sea yesterday he subdued
a highly dangerous patient quite handily is this
noise you said his name was hea delusional
oh extremely the patient got so wound up by
one of no's stories that he beat him up are they
talking about him we seen him Doctor Who he going
act like he's not never came right like you don't
have a partner Marshall you came here alone oh my
goodness oh Max F going somewhere heading
out to the fer so ah I'm afraid it's the
other way if you'll wait a moment I'll
find you someone who can take her to
the dock oh oh no no no no no ah what's
this it's it's just a sentive what you
going to do kill me provoke can you
forgive me what doesn't provoke you
wounds can't create monsters you are
wounded Marshall stab him yeah all
right got a lot of drugs kicking
in are you in a position to
drive what are you doing baby you got
to get to the ferry if the world thinks
that Chuck is dead and he's perfect for
their experiments I he going to burn the
car I love this thing because you gave
it to me the truth is there's one ugly
tie I actually thought it was quite cute
yeah oh why no
oh [Music] whoa wow that was a
really cool and interesting shot
yeah how do you get to that Lighthouse yeah
right you just got to swim there I guess so
it's not like it's super super far oh it's
probably freezing like we said earlier in
the film he's used to cold Waters yeah wow
such a looming shot [Music] there all [Music]
right God is there not going to be anything in
here maybe it's hidden it's just not in plain
sight oh it's really hitting him hard
cuz you said what 36 to 48 hours right
yeah the rifle's empty by the way oh my goodness
so he's the patient he is the experiment yes
he's here have Dr Shen take a look at your man
before you send him up oh Dr Sheen get out of
here Teddy this place is going to be the end
of you huh what the is this claw premine the
same thing we've been giving you for the
past 24 months what you've been here what
for 2 years a patient of this institution
so how was he on that boat that was in his
mind I guess ended the mark SL you were a US
Marshall you broke into toward C4 proof of the
67th patient notice anything these four names
have in common oh Edward Daniels has exactly
the same 13 letters as Andrew lus the same as
Rachel solando and Dolores chanal uh your name
is Andrew lus the 67th patient at ashcliff he's
you Andrew we got that part right your crime is
terrible one you can't forgive yourself for so
you invented another self uh oh did he do his
own wife oh did they have kids cuz the little
girl yeah he I think he did he he his kids but
you're violent trained dangerous you're the most
dangerous patient we have have a transcript of
the conversation you had with no yesterday this
is about you and ladies if he's as violent as
he's claiming why is he allowed to be in the room
with him with right you did this no no he meant
that it was my fault you almost killed him we can
bring you back to sanity now permanent measures
will be taken to ensure you can't hurt anyone
ever again oh my God but what about my partner
you're going to tell the US Marshall's office
that he's a defense mechanism ah what who are
you tell me don't you recognize me Andrew I've
been your primary psychiatrist for the last 2
years what I'm Lester Sheen oh all right that is
incredible okay what a twist if we fail with you
then everything that we've tried to do here will
be discredited everything that's the important
thing oh God this one's loaded I can tell by
the way my initials are on the side there's
a dent in the barrel from when Philip stack
shot him and Blast away the only way you're
ever getting off this island who what Andrew
please don't oh what what what didn't we just
see blood splatter what yeah what is it's fake
what oh lying and cigarett all you done is lying
your children Andrew your children oh so
they were his children yep you never had
any children your wife drowned them oh it was his
wife wasn't him we got him just outside Oklahoma
must have stopped 10 places in between here and
Tulsa I could sleep for a week theoris oh no
Dolores makes sense now why she's
always wet in his yeah where are the
kids they're in school is it summertime
yeah it's it's like sick it's Saturday
honey school's not in on Saturday my school
is oh my God that n was a crazy delivery D
yeah no please cut please
cut
wow
let's put them at the table Andrew we'll dry them
off we'll change their clothes
tomorrow we can take them on a
picnic Set Me Free I love you too I love
you so much I love you right what [Applause]
[Music]
oh
Andrew oh Rachel ohel wow wow Rachel these
are crazy twists going on here why are you
here cuz I killed my wife why did you do that
because she murdered our children who's Teddy
Daniels he doesn't exist now that is
Rachel solando I made them up why did
you make them up cuz I can't take knowing
that Dolores killed our children I killed
them cuz I didn't I didn't get her help
you know I need to know you've accepted
reality my name is Andrew lus
and I murdered my wife in the
spring of 52 wow so what's our next
move you you tell me got to get off
this rock chuck get back to the mainland
whatever the hell's going on here it's
bad labotomy on him don't worry about him
they're not going to catch us that's right
we're too smart for him yeah we are aren't
we feel like he's saying that on uh DiCaprio
is saying that on purpose to him yeah I'm
like is he actually regressing or is it a
fake regression I feel like it's a fake
regression you know this place makes me
wonder he Sarah Conor bring it out of there
which would be worse to live as a monster
or to die as a good man either die a hero or
live long enough to see yourself become the
villain H I knew I was like are we
not going to know they're going to
just black out right I knew
it oh my God ah how do you do
that wow this is definitely one of those films
where I mean cuz you're processing so much
information the first time you watch it I don't
think I said one word towards the end I just I was
I was just like yeah ditto yeah uh yeah because
not a lot keeps you and I usually mute um so um
but yeah no this is one of those I mean I I love a
good mystery film um and I love the psychological
aspects of this film uh very much so but this
is definitely one of those films where you got
to watch it a second third or even fourth time
to pick up different layers of things that were
again because there's so much stuff being thrown
at you from the first time you're like like like
I said there were times where um it's like okay
blanks are being filled in now um so but I mean
the twists and the turns I know we were able to
process uh that okay we're assuming Leo is 67th
patient but it was more late into it after he was
talking to noise yeah yeah that was once he got
to jackier Haley's character of noise but I mean
even even once we deduced that there was still
so much more of the I mean cuz yeah like when we
were watching that he was uh seeing the visions
of his wife I mean I figur that was all from
either PTSD you know from Miss and also PTSD
just from missing her as well on top of the war
stuff but also when he was getting the visions of
seeing the the children I'm like why is he getting
visions of what was Emily mortimer's charact that
was before the reveal of Holocaust yeah but well
yeah I mean or as a Vic well I figured that those
were Emily mortimer's children you remember cuz
they said those were her three children I like
why do we keep getting cuz I mean I'm sure he
feels terrible about what happened but why do
we keep getting it was just such a smart way I
just I love the uh just so many different plot
it just this movie just messed with my yeah
fittingly so messed with my mind um but what
do you think of this film oh God I mean it was
great I do agree that the setups of him flashing
back to like his War days and we we you said you
like does he feel a sense of responsibility uh in
regards to like the war even though he was just
there and it's like putting now putting Emily's
like uh in there with the girl brought it all back
to like he does cuz he killed his wife right yeah
uh yeah there's so much normally I feel like in
a movie I number one I love the soundtrack it's
such it's so huge and so epic and every time they
would they would get to the location then it would
just like stop which I I really I really enjoyed
the cinematography especially the crane shots were
amazing and the sound design gave me so much
anxiety every time I was lighting a match it
just was like you felt like you were right there
lighting it and it was going to burn your fingers
um all of those it it kept me on edge and I feel
like mainly most movies I can or we could see
what's coming yeah and I did not I didn't I did
not and everyone in here is just so brilliant oh
yeah and grounded and just I never normally when
I'm sure when we watch movies there's always like
a character or two that you can kind of feel like
I feel like they're acting and in this I was like
I was never like as an actor right I tend to
notice those things more and in this I it was
never taken out by anybody it just was so they
were so in character like literally um so much no
and I agree with you like just from all the sound
design and the and the score I'll have to look up
when we're done but the score um was just I was
just I just felt like and also too just again from
the setting too I just I felt anxiety and and a a
sense of claustrophobic yes uh you know just from
just everything happening but and even too once
we had deduced that he was the 67th uh patient
it didn't M because there was so much else going
on you know from the what we had learned with his
wife and then uh that it was their children and
that all these names were just what anagrams or
whatever um so I mean there was again I just loved
all the twist uh I loved what you mentioned too
about the cinematography it was the crane shots
it was it was just so beautifully done then there
was some uh really nice zoom in shots as well
uh I also noticed too it said uh when we were
watching the credits here that it said that they
had a psychiatric consultant you can tell there
was a lot of care that went into this because
again like after just watching this and fresh
talking about it like I'm just this is such a this
film was just such a mind trip yeah um just really
got to me in that way because like I said we we
don't usually not say anything when we're watching
a movie right but I didn't have I was just like
uh yeah it's one of those types of films you in
it yeah for sure um but DiCaprio I mean that guy
just he never ceases to amaz his performance was
incredible and I mean it's quite I love seeing the
progression of change too once we get the reveals
his not only yeah all that too and like his hair
just how everything just starts coming unglued
like cuz when he first comes on to the island yeah
we see that he gets seasick and all that I mean
that's just a normal thing for a lot of people but
you can just see uh that sense of like Authority
and confidence when he comes on like he's going
to catch uh the Rachel whoever's missing uh and
just like the sense of entitlement of hey I'm
here to do a job I'm going to do it and get off
the island and then like like just getting crazier
and losing like a sense of mobility and all that
just in general and I just I thought he just
did such a great job of just like feeling that
like just I felt so bad for his character just
like progressing throughout the film watching
him lose his mind s to speak literally um but
just what a phenomenal performance um but yeah
and this film just did such a great job of again
just repeating myself even though we figured out
he was the 6 I had no idea what else was going
on I mean there were so many times like what's
What's Happening Here what's happening here what's
going on here and then when it was really I didn't
see that coming so I'm always happy when films
can Shock Me Not only just shock me but Shock Me
In A satisfying way to where it's you know it it
Services the storyline and the characters uh and I
thought this film just did that in phenomenal ways
this is really intriguing film and I can't wait to
see it again because there were so many like this
is again one of those films where you got to watch
it a second third time where you're like okay
that way you can sort of pick out yeah cuz now
you know the twist you know what's coming now it's
like okay now I can pick up on certain things that
um and I did mention earlier too I know you're
going to have no idea what I'm talking about I
would assume because I know the show ended in 2011
on season 10 this is where my crazy memory comes
up but I'm talking about Smallville there was an
episode of small Ville that they did I believe it
was season 6 where Clark Kent I think you know who
that is Tom Wellings Clark Kent he was in a psych
ward uh he was being it was a phantom uh from
um uh the uh from um uh where Jerel keeps them
um and anyways uh he was in like a psych where it
was a very similar uh storyline to this so I just
my mind kept on going back to this it didn't quite
end as similarly as this but um yeah the way this
ended though I was like oh jeez it's so ambiguous
but you know it is but also too if you remember
do you remember the opening shot opened even
though it was foggy it opened on a white light
mhm so I it was very you know when I watched that
the second time I was almost like is this kind of
a dreames like you know what I mean opening kind
thing cuz is this setting us up so that at the end
we know like was this all a dream yeah well just
or in his head right type of thing so um yeah no
there was just a very very interesting film like
I said mind trip DiCaprio was phenomenal King I
mean all the actors were so good Allstar cast too
amazing amazing I mean when you got cing DiCaprio
I'm sure everyone's everyone's going to be like
please let me be in it seriously all the allstar
are going to want to join but um the the setups
the writing the cinematography the music the sound
design the acting um the twists there's just so
many different things I could praise about this
movie and I know especially like towards the end
though too with Michelle when they they actually
displayed the the killing of how she did it and
how it was revealed of her coming up to him and
and her saying mine's not like her it's not a
school day or whatever whatever that line is she's
saying it's it's a school day for her and then you
cut to the kids you're setting it up really for
him as like a human being realizing that is the
moment that has led him so far cuz before seeing
all this and us going maybe he's a 67th patient
kept us guessing why he would be that person un
even hearing like the the the stories or whatnot
it wasn't until like you're really placed with
them there at the end seeing how it was revealed
that he that was his wife made it um gave him a
little more like of the humanity so when you
when you hear him confess to saying I killed
my wife because she murdered my three children
and then we see him sort of acting like yeah we
got to I got to get off this rock man they they
I got to get out of here whatever's happening is
not good you're like H yeah is he regressing or
is he faking and I'm like wouldn't be surprised
if he's regressing because a lot of what he just
said is so much and they gave us a picture into
that right yeah um do you remember what the I'm
sorry but do you remember what that note I know
the note had the 67 but it had something about the
number four right the only reason I mentioned that
is because it was his his three children and his
wife right so that's the four and then he's the 67
so I assume that's the par okay and also too they
did show us at the beginning or when he was in the
um I believe it's the first night he was staying
there if you remember she was dripping wet in his
in that uh in the dream or whatever and then he
was Dripping we're like wait how did that happen
then we saw that the water was coming but I think
they were just they were setting us up because
from all she obviously she had drown the children
and then he had gone into the water so yeah I mean
there was just so like again that's the when you
watch the movie again you're going to notice these
things that's why it's like he's saying I just
don't do well with water in the beginning it
adds it all you're like you're literally screwed
from like water in general makes bad I didn't
even think about that makes total I was making
that Titanic joke at the beginning which still
makes sense but um no that makes I didn't even
think about that but had you not said that when
I'd watched now the second time like okay now I'm
understanding now why if he's anywhere near water
he's he's going to like feel vomity or not or feel
sick not well yeah not well because there would be
major PTSD anywhere near any kind of water so of
water so yeah that makes total sense the ending
too with the nurse coming out you see it in the
napkin it looks like the long like needle that
they're going to yeah uh right there in the old
eye I'm just glad they didn't show that I'm glad
they didn't do that either um and you just kind
of go yeah cutting to the lighthouse we see the
Fate that awaits us uh I guess but it's funny
cuz they're saying when they when they were in
the lighthouse before it was all revealed saying
you're kind of our last chance to prove that what
we're doing here is good right that what they're
doing is is a good thing um and then the thing at
the end I'm like but does that mean they're gonna
lobotomize him because they're trying to fight
against doing that right well that was the last
that was the their last ditch effort right have
have you seen just curious cuz I don't want to
spoil for you but have you seen Total Recall with
Arnold or no I think so but it's been a long time
and I might not have cuz the ending uh just with
how ambiguous it was without going to spoilers in
case you ever do react to it cuz it's been a while
the the ending with how ambiguous and talking
about labotz just very similar I'm not again I'm
not accusing them of coping anyway just it just
reminded me how similar it was to the ending of
Total Recall with Arnold just how ambiguous and
talking about lobotomization and all that so uh
interesting but yeah yeah but uh again just that
was an interesting point you threw out as well
in terms of at the very be I I didn't even think
about that uh when he was uh on the ship and he
was uh getting sick there just with the water so
again they're just setting us up but I think also
scres did that as well not only to set us up but
hey we know you're going to watch this a second
third or fourth time now when you watch this this
is why he's getting sick here yeah absolutely I
mean I eight and a half out of 10 maybe even nine
I don't know it's it's a great film everybody in
this is so freaking good the score is great yeah
the the direction the shots everything just draws
you in I'm like it's just like a it's a 10 out
of 10 type of a film I mean I I don't know really
anything wrong with it except I got mad I wanted
even though it's such a long movie at the end I
still was like ah I felt it coming where you just
see the lighthouse and they're going to cut out of
it but I wanted I wanted a little a little more of
it but I yeah great fil i' probably go e between
an 8.8 and a nine somewhere somewhere in that
in that range I mean it was it was a real good
character study um psychological mystery uh film
uh just so many different things Andi once again
just man never sees us doam ma uh just directed
the hell of this him and uh DiCaprio such a good
team those guys they can do no wrong together
uh but I really enjoyed this film I'm looking
forward to watching it again just picking up
on things I didn't catch the first time just
again I assume like many of you just there's so
much information to pick up the first time just
like anything you watch but especially with a film
like this and also too I wasn't expecting it to be
so heavy-handed I didn't not going to lie I didn't
know too much about this movie I just knew it took
place on an island which is not too much a stretch
cuz it's called shedar Island and there was some
psychological aspects but I wasn't I had no idea
there was a wife and there was all this and I just
didn't know it was going to be so heavy-handed
um so uh but they handled it in you know such
a a a satisfying way and and such a mature way
um and it was just a really well done film and
again sces and DiCaprio another winner for them
uh fantastic job so yeah I would say 8.8 to n
somewhere somewhere in that range yeah and also if
anybody wants to put together edit together like a
montage of those beautiful flashback shots every
one of those shots was pure art beautiful oh yeah
and the dream sequences doing the Flash oh God
yeah thank you so much chef's kiss yeah right
unbelievable I think that's it you got any last
words I mean we we like this this is a beautiful
piece of film art is that my phone I think it
was if it kept going off I'm sorry hope you guys
didn't hear it uh uh no just uh again fantastic
job by Ces DiCaprio all the other actors that
they got uh score cinematography sound design
everything pristine thumbs up fantastic art in
this film so great film glad I got to react to it
with you and to all you uh citizens of the reject
Nation thank you for joining us much appreciated
thank you so much we'll see you next time
bye